die welt verbessern mit globetrotter ein
spezialist für maßgeschneiderte reise
wartet seit über 40 jahren
globetrotter sie sind für menschen dar
denen es weniger gut geht
sie handeln wenn andere noch regen
sie machen die welt zu einem besseren
ort
sie sind die weltverbesserer
[Musik]
manuel bauer ist hoffotograf des dalai
lama in nepal hilft er mit das dorf
samsung das vom klimawandel bedroht ist
an einem besseren ort neu aufzubauen
die arbeiten laufen auf hochtouren wenn
er zur neuen weg setzt sich für
flüchtlinge auf der balkanroute 1 in
griechenland packen sie zweifel am sinn
ihrer arbeit
trotzdem macht sie weiter die ärztin
melanie holzkern leitet die
unfallchirurgie in einem äthiopischen
spital
jetzt geht ihr einsatz zu ende sie muss
abschied nehmen
jörg pelzer der gründer des
hilfsprojekts in äthiopien muss in der
schweiz sponsoren überzeugen
für den bau eines neuen spitals fehler
noch 15 millionen franken
familie und wenn es kleines wunder
wir sind in äthiopien im
universitätsspital von schema es ist das
einzige spital für zehn millionen
menschen
[Musik]
wimmer liegt 350 km südwestlich von der
äthiopischen hauptstadt addis abeba
rahim al bahri und der vater waren zwölf
stunden unterwegs
sie kommen zur nachkontrolle der
neunjährigen musste vor einem monat der
linke arm amputiert werden nur so konnte
ihr leben gerettet werden
hallo regina wie geht's wie geht alles
in ordnung
das gespräch mit dem vater in amharisch
der äthiopischen amtssprache muss
oberärztin melanie holz kann ihren
kollegen überlassen
das regina und ihr vater trotz des
weiten weges zur nachkontrolle kommen
freut die ärztin
denn viele patienten sieht sie nach dem
austritt nie wieder erlebt in einer
großfamilie mit neun geschwistern ihr
vater befürchtet dass sie mit ihrem
handicap später keinen mann finden und
keine eigene familie gründen kann das
reicht nicht
[Musik]
da kannst du ihr sagen es sieht gut aus
ich ziehe jetzt die fäden hier sitzen
das arabische wort für kein problem hat
sich melanie gemerkt gut gut und noch
das gut gemacht
melanie holz kann glaubt dass rechner
mit der neuen situation zurecht kommt
aber ihr leben hing an einem seidenen
faden
ohne not operation wäre china gestorben
[Musik]
auch dieses mal wird das
trostpflästerchen riemer al bahri
erwartet wohl kein einfaches leben aber
die unterstützung ihrer familie ist ihr
gewiss das ist aber schon das neue dorf
im osten das auf 3600 meter über meer
entsteht im alten dorf seinem song wird
das leben wegen der wasserknappheit
immer schwieriger manuel bauer hofft
dass mit dem neuen dorf die gemeinschaft
erhalten und die abwanderung verhindert
werden kann
dafür reist er immer wieder nach nepal
in die hauptstadt kathmandu und nimmt
den weg über chanson nach lohmann tang
auf sich um mit den menschen aus samson
ein neues tiefer gelegenes dorf zu bauen
der winter brachte viel schnee und
lawinen im frühling forderte ein starkes
erdbeben geben 9000 menschen leben eine
katastrophe das dorf samson war nicht
direkt betroffen zum neuendorf müssen
alle familien ihren teil beitragen
in form von arbeit und geld umgerechnet
150 fremden aus sicherheitsgründen wird
nun mit stein statt mit lehmziegeln
gebaut das wird teurer
das tut mir weh und ich weiß dass einige
dass sie ihren beitrag geleistet dass
sie beziehungen zu ihrem dorf will sie
auch wie kleister verstopfen das nicht
einfach so anpflanzt über können lamanna
wann der als mönch ein hohes ansehen
genießt relativiert seine zweifel
die meisten familien können das
aufbringen
sie haben ziegen wenn sie eine verkaufen
bekommen sie dafür um die 150 schweizer
franken die mit tieren haben kein
problem die anderen schon
ja aber es ist nicht so wie geld und mit
ihren geschäften im winter ist es doch
ein fairer preis für den dort wo hat
manuel bauer zusätzlich nepalesische
arbeiter angestellt und von jeder
familie aus samson hilft jemand mit als
fotograf dokumentiert er die entstehung
muss schritt für schritt
[Musik]
diese bilder werden ihm helfen in der
schweiz spenden gelder aufzutreiben
[Musik]
damjanovic ist unermüdlich unterwegs um
flüchtlingen zu helfen ihren einsatzort
hat sie von serbien nach griechenland
verlegt nun arbeitet sie in die domäne
an der grenze zu mazedonien seit der
grenzschließung sitzen hier über 10.000
menschen fest zusammen mit ihrem freund
samir chalabi verteilt wanja säcke mit
essen und hygiene artikel
sie tun das in der nacht am tag würden
sie überrannt ich komme hier sind
panthers auf ihrem gang durch das lager
trifft man ja auf eine syrische familie
die auf dem nackten boden schleift
schutzlos der kälte ausgeliefert der
mann aus syrien schildert die prekären
umständen es gebe weder essen noch
trinken
[Musik]
der will gar nicht einfach authentisch
windows sowie ist dass der spruch mit
dem us cent im schlaf im frühjahr und
die braucht es nun ist einfach entweder
dura oder schicken ist zurück das tut
mir jetzt ziemlich weh es ist ein appell
nach europa locken die kinder da und
logan ist kinder und verglichen es ist
lasst uns gehen also wirklich also
psychisch macht er seine show fertig
will wenn du erste bist bringt dass
unsere glücklich dieses trainer mit
seinem kleinen päckli dann kommt man
schon ins gespräch man funktioniert man
vergisst das ganze elend eigentlich
heute wenn man meine mentale tun denn da
braucht man eine zehner und lacht und
der gurt oder wenn studiert okay ist
eine disco hits gemacht bereichen
schlecht oder gar nicht gemacht
wie hilft ich weiß nie wie sehen das die
stadt und zur zivilen ganze sache
mühle
im spital in china ist heute ein
besonderer tag für melanie holz kann
acht wochen lang hat sie hier die
unfallchirurgie geleitet jetzt muss sie
abschied nehmen
es war schön mit dir ich hasse
abschieden geh einfach weg mit dir ein
blick ins buch in dem die operationen
verzeichnet werden zeigt wie viel die
chirurgin in den letzten acht wochen
bewältigt hat es waren komplexe fälle in
der schweiz hätte sie in dieser zeit
knapp ein drittel geschafft
melanie holz gang lässt viele patienten
zurück ihr nachfolger trifft erst in
zwei wochen ein und vieles funktioniert
nicht so wie es sollte
das hier lässt sich nicht mehr richtig
bewegen und sie sind so kompetenten
notfall auch das riesenrad passiert und
das ex patient darauf zu achten dass ich
den suchen
ich verabschiede mich ich komme zurück
versprachen danke für alles
[Musik]
in den vergangenen zwei monaten hat
melanie das einheimische team schätzen
gelernt
sie hat erlebt dass die kollegen bis zu
60 stunden durcharbeiten
unter oft schwierigsten bedingungen
gewusst was man wirklich was mir
wirklich eine ist das noch nicht
[Musik]
das spital delsberg ist der arbeitsort
von chefarzt york pelzer
er hat melanie für die unfallchirurgie
und für äthiopien begeistert und er ist
der gründer des congstar projekts
für den geplanten spitalneubau in china
fehlen ihm noch 15 millionen franken
er trifft potenzielle sponsoren alles
freunde
sein alter freund george immer hat
eingeladen
fast alle hier haben peltzer den sie nur
pele nennen schon mit spendengeldern
unterstützt
sie gehören zum kreis jurassische uhren
industrieller sind gut gebucht und
vernetzt einige begleiteten pelzer schon
auf einer velotour durch äthiopien und
spendeten beträchtliche summe ich bin
etwas verspätet ich hatte viele
patienten kein problem
setz dich mit projekt us-vision eines
traumazentrums in china stößt auf großes
interesse
vielen dank für diese einladung
die idee ist nun dass wir in einem
großen zentrum chirurgen aus sudan
somalia tansania und südafrika ausbilden
wir bieten fortbildungskurse an die in
europa oder der schweiz
das fehlt in afrika vollständig wir
werden zum ersten und wichtigsten
ausbildungszentrum für traumatologie in
afrika das ist das ziel des neuen
spitals und dann kehren sie in ein land
zurück
unbedingt sie werden ausgebildet und
erhalten am ende
den titel eines auf orthopädie
spezialisierten trauma chirurgen das ist
das ziel eines der modernsten spitäler
afrikas zu werden spender gewinnen
das ist ein existenzieller teil der
arbeit eines jeden weltverbesserers
bewiesen und zeige doch noch gut macht
wenn es nicht kaputtmachen ende druck
ist falsch und überzogen und sehr
spannende arbeit
[Musik]
in muss dann nimmt das neue dorf nummer
schon gestalt an
aber ein wichtiger teil fehlt noch ein
damm der die menschen vor
überschwemmungen geschützt
manuel bauer berät sich mit
einheimischen ingenieuren wie breit soll
das fundament werden
wie groß muss es sein 300 millimeter 301
meter 27 17 27 ich glaube das ist viel
zu schwach wenn das gerät kommt ich
zeige aber was weißt du dich das
fundament sollte in etwa so seien bei
einer höhe von drei metern
was meint ihr
[Musik]
soll es so einen daumen ganz ohne flur
das ganze wie immer wieder neue probleme
bewältigen auch das verbindet die
weltverbesserer
in zürich haben wir neue beach und der
verein wurde free association eine
sitzung
wanja brief die mitarbeitenden über den
einsatz in griechenland geht für 1500
menschen alles und immer sind zählt es
gibt keine sanitäranlagen sind sagt
frank stocker sieht also es wirklich
wenn man fragt was brauchen jährliches
gerne so schnell wie möglich noch einmal
erstand option sowie domain machen will
wenn man einfach besser gefällt das obst
x tiger wie sie damit dass offene fragen
manche das ist einfach mein vater
erschwert im vorstand arbeiten über 20
personen als freiwillige mehr als
familie wehrmann gold wirklich durch die
kunden miteinander karli sa durch geld
wenn jetzt neue witsch ist neue
geschäftsführerin
erstmals soll sie nun ein salär erhalten
um ihre spesen zu denken
[Musik]
im gästehaus im äthiopischen jim wohnen
die ärzte aus der schweiz die hier
freiwillig für das größte projekt
arbeiten
nach zwei monaten unentgeltlichen
einsatz auf der unfallchirurgie will
sich melanie holz gang auf ihre weise
vom land das sie so sehr fasziniert
verabschieden
[Musik]
das ist ganz tolle erfahrung sie
wirklich durch und persönlich wahnsinnig
viel klein-klein sicher wieder brachte
zentimeter so schön wenn die vegetation
zum beispiel die palme der riese buhlt
mit der honig fast allen übrigens
unglaublich schön und hat einfach sehr
natürlich sehr und er wird aber erst
wird melanie in die schweiz zurückkehren
und im spital uster als oberärztin
arbeiten
die pfälzer in einem seltenen moment der
mut beim wandern im wald hier in der
natur kann der chefarzt nachdenken und
über das leben sinnieren
[Musik]
das sind vom lager schicken das wetab
stück das heuer besonders sie wie
günther h aber irgendwo muss grün etwa
noch bestand hat der 51 jährige liebt
sport auf seinem fahrrad touren durch
äthiopien legt er hunderte von
kilometern zurück je mehr man gebe umso
mehr erhalte man zurück ist er überzeugt
sie mit vielen sache wenn man nicht muss
bisky und schwitze und das engagement
gibt den ich hat freut wenn es erreicht
hat nicht so groß also ich glaube spaß
hunde mit dass man sachen erreicht
vodafone pflicht unmöglich sie sind oder
nur schwer erreichbar
ausgeprägte willensstärke und ein
unerschütterlicher glaube dass alles gut
wird
auch das ist eine gemeinsamkeit der
weltverbesserer
[Musik]
in zürich bereitet sich manuel bauer auf
seinem vortrag vor großem publikum vor
er will die menschen für sein projekt in
samsun begeistert und geld seien mit der
öffentlichkeit steigt aber auch der
druck will jetzt das projekt aber nach
augusta tragen private gespült hatte
schon du trauen angst dass man es nicht
einmal bis zu vier könnten steinig 10
und das hat das spiel also das feature
druck grad will mit medien durch das
projekt und ja das beschäftigten das
könnte
[Applaus]
und so hat ein samt sommer setzte summe
art von alsdorf bauer
sie haben klimmzüge herstellt
gigantische menge von einem zirkus um im
traditionellen stil die häuslbauer durch
leider hand unwetter ein teil von den
erzieher oder zerstört doch sie hat den
entschieden
ein süßer dann halt nicht steigt was ein
moderner und besseres und mir haben sie
da unterstützt damit arbeitskräfte will
mir mit märkten
das muss gut sie damit nachhaltig ist
hat er ihnen ein grüner arbeiter zur
siebter stelle so im staat das dorf die
umsiedlung bis jetzt haben wir sagt
seine söhne fertig bauen
vor dem winter vor acht seriöser im
traditioneller tibetischer stil
manuel bauers ausführung kommen gut an
das publikum zeigt sich großzügig der
erlös dieses abends wird den menschen in
mustang helfen das neue dorf fertig zu
stellen
[Musik]
die domain ii warten über 10.000
menschen darauf dass die grenze nach
mazedonien wieder geöffnet wird
wann er zum neuen beach hat ein zelt
organisiert
sie ist gut
hoffentlich danke erzählt welches
infiziere hinteregger und der letzte
verteiler ohnehin schon kochs usa und in
der küche halten sie zusammen klar
flüchtlinge hätten bei der zubereitung
der mahlzeiten mit so kommen täglich
2000 menschen zu einem dauerhaften
gratis essen wo man damit rechnet oder
wenn es kaputt gold wenn man vor allem
darum hat ihr verein in der schweiz
wieder zu spenden aufgerufen
das ist viel für die ganze woche
ihr müsst mich weil es bei der
essensausgabe schon zu chaotischen
szenen kam gibt es jetzt einen strikten
ablauf sala ein flüchtling amtet als
eine art sicherheitschef jetzt is
actually zu russlands vize gäste
geregelt es ist ganz wichtig
die linsensuppe die dschirga findet
reißenden absatz
bin selbst das ganze team auf die
flüchtlinge mit elf mannschaften auf
spenden von der schweizer fans bin ich
ziemlich mir macht es auf leute einfach
gratis bessergehen meistern es ist noch
suppe so bricht aus tut mir leid
[Musik]
im gästehaus in china bereiten melanie
holz gang und ihre kollegin das
abschiedsfest vor
[Musik]
juni
wie z
[Musik]
am abend wird melanie vom team der
unfallchirurgie ausgiebig gefeiert
das ist so nett dass ich es schütteln
von dem ist das öffnen öffnen ist das
von dir das ist wunderschön ist es war
verwöhnt mich so melanie wird das alles
vermissen bedachten geld
jetzt sofort wieder machen
[Musik]
ok
mit
[Musik]
die bauarbeiten in der mischung
verzögern sich eine folge des schweren
erdbebens vor drei wochen hier oben
blieb man weitgehend verschont aber die
nepalesischen arbeiter aus dem tiefland
wollten sofort rein
gerade in dieser schwierigen zeit will
manuel bauer für die menschen da sein
[Musik]
kleine hand gut entschieden dass es
vorwärtsgeht dass mir jetzt da sind und
die sachen übergang wohl nie ganz alles
fertig ist
zur wiener hof nicht gern zeigen dass
mehr atom erdbeben und wieder machen das
ganz wichtig sie will für sie heißt es
auch immer das ganzes jahr verlust wo
sie mit der schwierigen situation in
some zogen mit immer nur weniger
verwaltung ins wanken
und jetzt können sie das immer wieder
nutzung die neue häuser beziehen und da
vorwärts machen das bringt ihn als
nächstes beim raesfelder honig beraubt
hat ich mache mir große sorgen um unsere
neuen häusern aber schon
der viele schnee im winter verhinderte
dass ich hierher kommen konnte um nach
den häusern zu sehen
nach dem erdbeben hatte ich noch größere
angst dass die häuser verschüttet sein
könnten
[Musik]
nicht fehlen darf die traditionelle
bemalung der häuser so haben es schon
die vorfahren gemacht
die prächtigen farben werden aus
natursteinen gewonnen die farben an den
wänden sollen den bewohnern schutz
weißes handeln und wohlstand bringen
normalerweise machen sie das beim
eingang einige häuser haben zudem auf
den dächern stupas in diesen drei farben
mit den farben sieht es jetzt viel
schöner aus
das wird wunderbar wenn das holz auf den
dächern ist
[Musik]
im griechischen grenzorte domäne sucht
man ja zur neuen beach zusammen mit sala
nach günstigen alternativen fürs essen
denn langsam droht das geld auszugehen
wie geht's und alle lieben sie und sie
sind günstig das ist wie ein fleischwolf
das ist für fleisch haben wir strom in
cent reichen die portionen aus zehn kilo
pro tag
dann entdeckt man ihr ein mädchen das er
besonders ans herz gewachsen ist
riesa wie geht's dir erinnerst du dich
an mich
gibst du mir ein bisschen mehr in den
usa verbrauchten kleine familie stehe
ich bin diese mediale mit wasser
vermischt gibt es 30
nächste woche geht's verlassen
weiter
weit über lohmann hinaus sind laute
klänge zu vernehmen die bevölkerung
feiert das thentie fest begrüßt den
frühling mönche bahnen das böse und
bitten um eine gute ernte
mit dabei sind auch manuel bauer und
seine freundin yvonne
das spezielle ist das mich sehr an die
frühen jahre reporters ein besseres
dieses lokals fest und übergaben zimmer
meteor ist so kommt es durch erdbeben
das jahr sind geblieben so viel tut ist
das in gange da kreist was für nepal
natürlich ganz schlimm ist und es ist
sehr lokals fest stehen zu schweren
jetzt auf dem platz 3 400 touristen dazu
die traditionelle reinigungs zeremonie
dauert mehrere tage
[Musik]
ihre nominierung die bösen geister wird
verjagt
und du mit dem ziel bürger oder um wird
s bahn tanz mach und es war viel
abschüsse und dann wird die 5 thomas was
böse darin verkörpert nicht mehr richtig
wahrscheinlich frühere und vertrieben
[Musik]
weiter
in der letzten folge ein bewegender
moment firma neubauer nach acht jahren
kann er das neue dorf den menschen aus
samsungs übergehen
unruhen in äthiopien machen york pelzer
einen strich durch die rechnung
seine radtour mit den spendern droht zu
scheitern
melanie holz kam es zurück in der
schweiz und arbeitet wieder im spital
uster die sehnsucht nach äthiopien
bleibt waren ja zur neue wird ihre hilfe
in griechenland aus sie eröffnet einen
kindergarten und eine schule
[Musik]
die welt vorbei
mit globetrotter ein spezialist für
maßgeschneiderte reisen weltweit sind
über 40 jahre beträgt ca